bosquet est c'est un battement de coeur conduisant
tout à l'intérieur oh et comment le
définissez-vous exactement je viens de faire une balle copiée peinte par une dame
laissez-moi vous dire le premier
mégaoctet bouche de James je connaissais un tel jour je
suis né
tout le monde va connaître mon nom ouais je
n'ai jamais abandonné  arrêtez de revenir James ils
veulent que les Rolling Stones ferment le
spectacle non j'avance je prends et je retourne je
comprends que tout a eu un hit record
ici c'est un gars les gars
[Applaudissements]
je fais trois je dois travailler dur pour une
pause  tour j'innovais
tous les jours ne vous inquiétez pas voici votre
homme est un génie
chaque homme plus grand parce qu'il est allé James Brown
What's Wrong Miguel ne fonctionne pas la musique
mais sonne bien c'est disponible Wow
si ça sonne bien alors ça fait du bien que
c'est musical tellement mauvais que je dis joue le
mmm c'est président je veux un peu de
Vietnam ils possèdent le Sega qui porte un
père super lourd aux chats
là-bas comment ils s'habillent
désolé pour les problèmes d'avion problèmes d'argent
c'est comme ça qu'ils tuent James Brown
papa tu veux descendre pour faire de l'attelage comme
manucure par défaut dr.  Déborah merci
Dr.  le patron de kieny vomero annule le
spectacle de demain
mr.  Mec la communauté noire ils
écoutent le gars 10 000 acres [ __ ] de
Boston Garden tu as 10 000 gens en colère
sur ta pelouse Je pèse ensemble
nous ne savons pas que tu vas arrêter une émeute
alors attends-toi à ce que tu arrêtes Oh personne en
dépense  l'autre jour
m.  Brown j'ai juste une autre question
quel est ton plat préféré
Bobby papa est une jolie femme blanche ce que nous
mangeons